hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in his piece technologies of the self
the
first movement or tradition the first
approach
that foucault is going to examine is one
that we can call
socratic or platonic it's perfectly fine
actually say socratic slash
platonic if you want to both sides
are are equally important i would say in
this
socrates himself as a person as a
philosopher
is really a catalyst for a number of
different
important ideas and approaches just
by the way that he lived the stands that
he takes
he is he's teaching in a certain respect
and inculcating
philosophy but we wouldn't really have
the socrates
of you know the apology and the
alcibiades
without plato and we're getting a
particular interpretation of socrates
through this because socrates remember
had many students
who interpreted his his uh teachings and
lifestyle and lessons in a number of
different ways so this is this is a
directly
platonic one and the two texts that
foucault
talks about one of them rather briefly
one of them
with a lot more care and attention is
the apology
and then the alcibiades which is
attributed to
plato and may or may not be by plato
we're going to talk about whether that
matters in a bit and you notice he's not
talking about any other
platonic texts that might be relevant
the symposium the republic
arguably the meno in certain respects
there's a number of different ones that
could have been brought in here so we're
going to
not worry too much about that the very
first
reference here is in giving examples
of what the the care of the self
you know was and how important it was
for ancient philosophy and so he says
in plato's apology socrates presents
himself before his judges
as a master of epimalea
how to that is the care of oneself the
care of the self within one
and he says you preoccupy yourself
without shame and acquiring wealth
reputation and honors he tells them
but you do not concern yourselves with
yourselves that is with wisdom
truth and the perfection of the soul
socrates on the other hand watches over
the citizens to make sure they concern
themselves
with themselves and foucault says that
well this is a very important
and sort of determinative passage
and it shows us a particular way of
understanding the care of the self you
know what what is going on here
foucault isolates out several uh lessons
we could say
three important things uh his his
mission was conferred on him by the gods
he won't abandon it except with his last
breath
for this task he demands no reward he is
disinterested he performs it out of
benevolence
and his mission is useful for the city
more useful than the athenians military
victory at olympia because in teaching
people to occupy themselves of
themselves he teaches them to occupy
themselves with the
city so these are some important
features right socrates is doing public
service
by engaging in philosophy with his
fellow
citizens and although he does have a
preference for talking with
younger people he also
talks with with people who are his own
age
and middle aged people who are beyond
the time period the the age
as a the greeks would say of youth and
so
he's inviting his fellow citizens
to care for themselves not to care so
much for honors
external goods like property you know
not to worry so much about military
victory itself
to worry instead about what it is that
they are doing
in relation to themselves getting to
know who they
truly are and what they truly are and
and
changing it in the process to make it
better to
nurse the wounded self we might say or
the
distorted self now a little bit later
in the text we get to the alcibiades
and fucos is the first philosophical
elaboration of the concern with taking
care of oneself i wish to consider his
phone and plato alcibiades
one uh the the date of its writing is
uncertain it may be a spurious platonic
dialogue
and then he says something kind of funny
here it's not my intention to study
dates but to point out the principal
features of the care of the soft which
is the center of the dialogue okay
so that's fine you know it may be a
dialogue by plato it may not
um it's a it's a scribe to plato is it
that important that it's by plato
you know we could take a similar
attitude to like you know people take
with uh
you know biblical books like is the book
of isaiah really by one guy named isaiah
probably not you know
instead it's by a school and and
foucault explicitly
references a much much later
platonic tradition neoplatonism and he
brings up
albinious and we could talk about others
as well
this is a gap of centuries and
i i think it's good to signal here
without going into deep criticism
that foucault is doing a little bit of
you know playing fast and loose with
with things here
uh if the text is indeed by plato that
that's great
there's some text that we are pretty
confident are by plato where the
care of the self could also be ferreted
out
why is he focusing then on this one well
he says the neoplatonus and the third or
fourth century a.d
show the significance given to this
dialogue and the importance it assumed
they wanted to transform plato's
dialogues into a pedagogical tool to
make them
to the matrix for encyclopedic knowledge
they considered
the alcibiades to be the first dialogue
of plato not the first written of course
but the first to be read the first to be
studied it was the arcade the starting
point the beginning point
in the second century albinis said that
every gifted young person who wanted to
stand apart from politics and practice
virtue should study the
al-sabihides it provided the point of
departure
and a program for all platonic
philosophy now
we should say okay that's that's at a
certain point in time quite far removed
from plato and they may be using the
dialogue in a very constructive and
creative way to do something different
so it becomes central to later platonus
pedagogy and practice and what we're
talking about is
is a time when you know neoplatonism
is also competing with the vestiges
of aristotelianism with skepticism with
epicureanism with stoicism with cynicism
with all these these uh post-platonic
philosophies
right now foucault
takes i think his his approach here is
quite interesting
he frames it around several in you know
some
good questions to ask the first of them
is why are socrates and alcibiades
brought to this question what's the
context and you know when it comes to
platonic dialogues
it certainly does help to know something
about the people who are named
especially if they're historical figures
with as rich a relationship to history
as
socrates and alcibiades elsa biodies by
the way
is kind of a golden boy of athens at the
time
and he is a great story of you know rise
and decline and fall he's kind of a
broken person
at the end of his career having managed
to betray
both the athenians and the spartans and
the persians
right and to to really
burn out in many respects rather than
fade away
so he has uh what are the reasons why
alcibiades and socrates are brought to
the notion of the care
of the self so this is taking place at a
time when alcibiades
is about to begin his public and
political life
he wishes to speak to before the people
and be all
all powerful in the city he's not
satisfied with his traditional status
with privileges of birth and heritage
you know we often think of
athens as a democracy and there was
democracy there
but it was also an incredibly you know
stratified society as well
coming from noble background was
important and alcibiades
has that so socrates
tells alcibiades that he can no longer
be the beloved
as a young man he must become the lover
he must be active
in the political and the love game and
so alcibiade is making a
transition and you can read the
text there's more discussion of that i
want to focus in on the very last
point the intersection of political
ambition and philosophical love
is the care of the self so
in the platonic perspective at least
if you are going to be
involved in politics or we could say in
society more generally it doesn't just
have to be what we think of
narrowly today is politics it could
involve all sorts of other
causes as well the intersection between
that
and as he says philosophical love eros
desire is the care of the self now
that doesn't tell us anything that's a
very nice slogan what does it mean
here we get to the second question why
should alcibiades be concerned about the
care
of the self and we're going back now to
the question
that is being raised by by socrates in
the apology
hey dummies why are you so focused on
these things that don't matter as much
and not on yourself why are you turning
your gaze outward
rather than you know reflecting it
inward on the kind of person you are
on who you indeed are and whether you're
in good condition
or not why should alcibiades be
concerned why and then why is socrates
such a busybody why does he have to mix
himself up in this and
you know here's one of the answers
that's not given there oh
well you know i don't want my city to be
a bad city so i've got to go around and
like make sure that everybody's doing
the right thing that's not how socrates
frames it
he frames it in terms of the person he's
talking to he's like
don't you want to be a better you don't
you want to actually understand
why you make the dumb decisions that you
do and you know why your ideas are all
mixed up isn't that a bad
thing for you to be so confused or to be
so confident about things that you
actually don't know
right that's something that runs
throughout the platonic texts
so why should alcibiades be concerned so
there's a couple features of the
dialogue that foucault rightly brings up
that i think are
really central here he says socrates
asks alcibiades about his personal
capacities and the nature of his
ambition
the ambition is one thing alcibiades has
ton of tons of that
does he have the capacities to make that
those ambitions happen right and
he says does he know the meaning of the
rule of law of justice or concord
alcibiades clearly knows nothing
so do we want somebody like this
actually being in charge
does somebody like that actually want to
be in charge
given how little he actually understands
about what it means to exercise
power so socrates says
let's let's compare our your education
with that of
persian and spartan kings your rivals
spartan and persian princes
have teachers in wisdom justice
temperance and courage now these are the
cardinal virtues
right we find these same four being
discussed throughout plato's corpus
and it goes on and becomes a major thing
for both epicureans
and for stoics as well you know these
these four are singled out as
particularly
important in the republic in the
symposium towards the end
in both agathon speech and in in
socrates discussion
of that in um you know the protagoras
with the addition of piety
in quite a few places within plato's
corpus these
are the things that make a person good
and how do you have those how do you
acquire those what what is the nature of
these cardinal virtues now foucault says
something interesting here
that and he's taking this from uh
the the dialogue he says socrates tells
alcibiades it's not too late
to help him gain the upper hand to
acquire
techne so here's where we get
technologies of the self right
techne is a word that we use oftentimes
we'll translate it as craft or skill
art right it's a kind of disciplinary
knowledge that allows you to do
stuff and although aristotle is going to
fairly
rigorously distinguish techne from
episteme
in plato they're not quite so separated
out from each other
so in order to acquire this alcibiades
must apply himself
he must take care of himself right and
that in part although it's not being
sketched out here is going to involve
reference to these cardinal virtues how
do you acquire these
how do you even know what they are so
that you can begin
measuring yourself against them and and
modifying yourself
to have them the third thing is
well okay so it's important to care for
the self
what does that mean there and there's
two aspects to this two key
parts well what is the self what is this
thing that we're calling the self
and what is its care
so foucault says what is this self of
which one has to take care and what does
that care consist so what is the self
self is a reflexive pronoun in in greek
and you know it is in in many other
languages as well
auto has two meanings it can mean the
same but it also conveys the notion of
identity so the latter meaning shifts
the question from what is this self to
departing from what ground
shall i find my identity how can i
figure out
who i am what i am what i want to be
and how to get there so he says
there's a dialectical movement when you
take care of the body you do not take
care of the self
the care of the self is the care of the
activity
and not the care of the soul as
substance so we're trying to figure out
well how
how does one figure out what the self is
in movement inactivity and choosing in
the middle of the screwed up
life that i'm already in and that i've
made a number of choices about right so
there's a dialectical
determination that's taking place
there's also a contemplation
that needs to happen as well he says
um what does this care consist
you have to know what the with the soul
consists of the soul cannot know itself
except by looking at itself in a similar
element
a mirror so here's a kind of a leap thus
it must contemplate the divine element
in this divine contemplation the soul
will be able to discover rules to serve
as a basis
for just behavior and political action
and so there's this contemplative aspect
to it as well which goes you know back
to the cardinal
virtue of wisdom and
a bit later um in the the
the piece foucault is going to say
in plato the themes of contemplation of
self
and care of self are related
dialectically
through dialogue and so this is a very
important point
in part because foucault frames it as if
this is something that's that's more
platonic than belonging to these other
perspectives where for example you might
just shut up and listen for
a while before engaging and asking
questions
you know your relationship to the the
teacher the the master
in uh socratic and platonic
dialectic there's a continual back and
forth uh you know reassessment a let's
figure
this out together and that can sometimes
be missing
in in later uh ways of
understanding the the care of the self
so that is uh
an important aspect he tells us that
there's four
key themes or problems
that are arising out of plato's
alcibiades and these are
less sort of like here's the answer more
like here's the questions you need to
figure out through this dialectical work
so one is the relationship of the care
of the self to political activity should
you be politically engaged
should you disengage yourself obviously
the answer from a socratic and platonic
perspective is no you you need to be
engaged in your society
that doesn't mean that you need to do
every single thing that every politician
does
there's some things that socrates
refuses to do and says
yeah i i don't i don't like go around
and try to get people to like me
that's not that's not my job that's not
my function right but there is this
question of the care of the self
and political activity if we want to
broaden this we could say any sort of
social activity
there's the question of the care of the
self and pedagogy
and at first he says he talks about it
just as pedagogy
which places the emphasis on well how
should we be teaching people
to care for the self a little bit later
in the text
he he identifies this as the relation
between the care of the self
and defective education right
so that's interesting and we should
pause on that for a moment
and consider that there's many ways in
which education can be defective
it can be defective by just not being
provided or being provided in too
rudimentary a way
this is the problem with a lot of
self-help right it's got all sorts of
like hey you should try this in your
life and then it's very superficial
it doesn't really go any further
[Music]
but it can also be defective by giving
you
wrong-headed ideas as if they're
actually the right ideas
and this is where like you know the
socratic process of dialectic
and uh you know socrates gets compared
to a stinging creature
that stupefies his listeners in the
aminos i brought up before the amino is
a good one for this
that's all part of this pedagogical
process and the care of the self
you don't want to be wrong about things
that really matter right
including what really matters care of
self and knowledge of self these are
closely connected in the platonic thing
who co-suggests that maybe knowledge of
self knothi say out to
is uh salton is taking too much
of a priority at some points
and then finally we have two he's got a
theme
that he identifies as a single theme and
i really think we could break it into
two
care of the self and philosophical love
and the relation to
the master now they could coincide
you're drawn by
eros to talk with somebody who knows
more
likes socrates being taught by deotama
about
love in the symposium in the story that
he tells right
but they could be dissociated as well
you could have a philosophical erotics
and they could also have like you go and
study with the master
and sit there in silence to the lectures
and then start doing the application
exercises and they don't actually
coincide
so i guess you could say that the
problematization of that
could also be a problem itself so this
is what foucault
depicts here it's a very incomplete
picture obviously
but he's not intending to provide a
complete picture
these are sort of starting points for
the care of the self
in ancient philosophy
you